hello everyone and welcome to another
great game that was suggested to me a
few days ago but I'm only covering it
now there was a lot of stuff happening
in the Chess World uh it's a game app
between uh pranav Anand and pregnant now
that's a lot of anans in their name uh
but uh this game deserves it uh if any
does as of course everyone was pregnant
and he's already a well-established
member of the I I dare say Elite of the
Chess World he is the the Slayer of
world champions uh and here he faces
India's newest Grand Master he is
India's 76th Grand Master and not only
did he achieve his Norm on the 15th of
September this year only a day after he
achieved his Grandmaster title not an
arm sorry uh he became the world under
16 youth Champion so uh quite uh quite a
gentleman we have here and this game
just shows you how how incredibly strong
both of them are and uh you guys will
enjoy it so let's dive straight into it
pranam island has the white pieces and
he opens with Pawn to D for the game is
from round four of the Asian Continental
Championship so let's uh let's enjoy it
we have Knight to F6 uh Pawn to C4 uh we
have E6 Knight the C3 and the bishop to
B4 we've already seen what proc can do
uh with the names of Indian defense we
have Ponte E3 going for the standard
stuff castles and Bishop to D3 The
Bishop's attack against denims of Indian
defense we have Pawn to D5 C characters
e captures and now Knight to E2 so very
very standard stuff Rook to E8 and the
bishop to D2 now so now the Knight is no
longer pinned uh the bishop usually
Retreats the D6 here progress for Bishop
to f8 again nothing uh really weird
happening here this is all the the
second most popular continuation Rook to
C1 and now A5 stopping B4 at some point
and also making sure that uh you can
comfortably play Knights the A6 so here
we have castles and now uh Knight to A6
right away and 6 are known moves but
here Pro goes for C6 and it is now as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game
sorry in the previous video I did not
mention we have a completely new game
but I did put it in the timestamps below
so hopefully I didn't confuse you guys
too much but yeah now completely new
territory uh and we have F3 uh taking
care of the the four square at some
point you of course are hoping to
execute E4 we have Pawn to B5 by prog
and now Knight to F4 a beautiful Square
for tonight it's unclear how black will
kick it away from there and now just
Knight the A6 if you go for B4 right
away which I know you guys are
interested in and just not A4 and yes
the Knight and the rim is demon you know
they do say that but here the Knight is
actually perfectly fine uh controls the
B6 and C5 squares for the foreseeable
future and later on if you don't like it
there you can play something like B3
Knight the B to move the bishop play the
Knight to D3 control E5 C5 uh the Knight
is okay here so okay after Knight F4 we
have knighted the A6 by Prague and now
Knight C to E2 uh opening of the the C
file for The Rook Bishop D7 product
defensive white Bishop D7 and why not
Bishop B7 is uh well uh way way above my
pay grade even the engine says Bishop to
B7 is better but Prague has um his own
style of playing he might have some
ideas of pushing C5 and then maybe he
wants the B5 Pawn defended or something
like that and here Anand goes for Pawn
to G4 he wants to eliminate the Knight
with the G4 or move it away from F6 H6
by Prague and now Queen to E1 now the
queen gains the access to all of these
squares but also you are attacking the
A5 pawn and you will grab it with Tempo
so here Bishop to B4 and this is where
the game really takes uh an exciting
turn because uh there there's only all
already a threat in the position which
may or may not be an actual threat now
what's the idea behind Bishop to B4 yes
you are stopping Bishop captures on A5
but also what about Rook captures and E3
the bishop is no longer capable of
capturing you would lose the queen so
what is is best for white to do here
well interestingly there are many ways
to continue the game for white here and
one of them is to even allow Rook
captures on E3 interestingly it was not
played in the game but I will just show
it for example H4 you allow Rook
captures on E3 and now you play A3 you
kick away the bishop if the bishop moves
then you can capture The Rook so black
will probably trade here captures
captures The Rook moves and now yeah and
can continue the attack with all of his
pieces attacking prox King so this would
be one way to do it he decides to bring
back the Knight Knight to C3 and now we
have Bishop back to D6 by proc uh we
have Queen to F2 uh the thread is now of
course just Bishop captures and f4d the
E Pawn cannot move so Queen to F2 you
don't want your queen staring at that
Rook honey 8 and now Prague plays Pawn
to C5 uh giving up the B5 Pawn so here
we have a very interesting approach to
the game where pranav Anand could have
sacrificed the pawn to start an attack
he didn't want to do it and now Prague
does not flinch he just gives up
opponent says all right now it's my turn
to attack Bishop captures on B5 uh Anand
grabs the pawn C captures on D4 e
captures on D4 and now Knight to B4 now
the bishop might be overloaded here uh
putting pressure on the bishop also you
might just lose the bishop here and then
you lose control over the D3 Square
which would be a shame so Bishop back to
E2 you have to keep an eye on the D3
square and now Queen to B6 by Prague we
have Pawn to A4 now again trying to win
that B5 square and Rook the E7 prog now
prepares the double up on the E file
Rook C to D1 uh and now Rook 8 to E8 we
have Bishop to B5 so the the bishop is
no longer um sort of a Target here and
now comes Queen to B8 which is a very
elegant solution you could also consider
just trading everything you've played
Bishop captures the Knight captures then
you could play Bishop captures here
Bishop captures and then win the E2
Square for your Rook but uh Prague has a
more elegant solution he plays Queen B8
now just threatens the pick up the
Knight and what do you do here Bishop
captures on D7 it's a nice in between
move Bishop captures Knight captures and
D7 and now Knight to H5 getting the
Knight out of Harm's Way and proc plays
Knight to f8 and here again pranav has
to be very very careful he should
continue with something like Queen G2 or
F4 uh just uh continuing the attack
against
um the black king and as long as the
Knight is on C3 you don't have to worry
about Rook to E2 and it doesn't seem
like there's a way for proc to eliminate
the knight from C3 is there but you guys
know there is because you've probably
seen the thumbnail so here we have
pawned the G5 advancing that point
preparing the capture open up the G file
maybe King H1 can be played maybe you
can put Rooks on the G file and now proc
plays the only move that sort of allows
him to not gain Advantage but to
continue playing this game in an equal
fashion and that is Knight to A2 and
look at this this is such a beautiful
move I mean a pure peace sacrifice just
to win the E2 square and it does look
like there should be something here so
what can you play here it's an
incredibly complicated position I will
tell you in the game Knight captures on
80 was played which is not the precise
way to to play this uh the best way to
counter an attack on the queen side most
often is to just focus on your own
attack on the king side because uh here
okay the king the white king is not on
the queen side black is not attacking
the white king black is just trying to
win the E2 square and here best would
would be to just play G captures on H6
and after Knight captures in C 3B
captures yes he would win the two square
but now you play Queen H4
and interestingly although it looks
disgusting you don't really care about
Rook captures and H2 because now once
you've captured this you have for
example Rook H2 Queen G5 or queen G4
you're already threatening Checkmate and
if Bishop captures you just move the
king incredible but but it works yeah so
here best for black would be something
like Rook 8 the E6 going for this check
here H characters on G7 Rook the G6
check and now you have to block Knight
to G3 and now Rook captures and G7 at
Checkmate is being threatened and the
game continues something like Rook F2
and white defended well however in the
game Knight captures and 80 was played
right away pranav Anand accepts prague's
sacrifice and now Prague goes for it
Rook to E2 Queen to H4 and now Rook
characters on H2 but now it's a bit
different now yes you do have um this
queen to G4 move and before I I take the
game further instead of this Rook
captures an HD move I will just show
Knights the G6 was a winning for Prague
right on the spot because now Queen G4
there's Queen characters on B2 and now
you don't really have a good move the
bishop cannot move and even if you play
G captures on H6 white is always down uh
Tempo Rook captures on the two Rook
captures Queen captures and now
everything is saying in this hanging
with check the Knight is saying on A2
there is no checkmating attack for white
so this is dead lost but in the game as
I mean this is incredibly complicated
Rook captures on H2 was played and now
Queen to G4 but now uh it's a difference
from the line that we've shown on Queen
G4 doesn't come with the mate threat G
captures an H6 was not played so here we
have Knight the G6 by Pro now Queen
captures on B2 isn't all that great if
Queen captures now you allow G captures
on H6 and now it's black who's defending
so after Queen G4 Knights the G6 you
have to play this um not only will the
Knight be used later on for attacking
purposes but also it stops any
checkmating ideas from White so here
Pawn to F4 uh this is in fact the best
move we have Rook e to E2 doubling up on
the second Rank and now comes G captures
an H6 now here with one final attempt
for white to try and save the game with
Knight to C3
uh you you have to force uh Queen trade
here a queen for two Rooks because
you're already up a piece and after this
check is given characters captures and
captures yes okay age captures on G5 uh
looks looks very scary but let's say
Knight B5 and white is perfectly fine
the engine in fact says this is 0.00 but
the engine often says it's 0.00 if you
played this you you wouldn't know what
to do with this position so let's say
Bishop captures on F4 Knight captures
and G captures and okay Knight and queen
and this uh pawn and F3 versus two Rooks
the bishop in the knight uh if played
well you will be able to defend however
after Rook e to E2 G captures and H6 was
played uh I mean it looks like a movie
wanna play but now uh the position is
completely winning for Prague if he
plays the correct move and the correct
move is Queen capture Sun B2 again but
Prague doesn't play it he plays Queen to
d8 which is which is a spectacular idea
and usually when a spectacular idea is
involved uh it's possible to defend
against it now progress idea is Queen to
H4 and then white just resigns because
if Queen captures then Rook eat the G2
will be Checkmate the queen no longer
covers the G2 square but there is one
move that saves the game for white and
it's an incredible one so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
move that allows white to survive this
game while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding your way
out of the deep dark forest and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop to E1 not a move you
would consider every day but it does
prevent Queen to H4 and without Queen
th4 there is no better move for pregnant
to just continue with Rook to G2 check
and once this is uh accomplished let's
say Rook captures Rook captures King
captures and now it's still very tricky
it's Prague who has the defend now he
has to find Queen to C8 he wants to play
Queen to C to check and pick up the Rook
here although even that would be
questionable because even if you allow
it you can block with Bishop to F2 then
the Rooks guard each other but still you
not only gain access to the C2 Square
you also gain access to the G4 square
and now after Knight the C3 you will
play Queen to G4 check Knight the G3 and
now Bishop captures on F4 and this is
the way for product uh continue the game
uh but it would be it would be equal
however after Queen to d8 Bishop to E1
was not found in the game night the C3
was played it's a move that works in all
the lines except this one now forcing
um uh sort of Rook to G2 check but now
uh that that was not played here Queen
to H4 this is the move the in between
move that that works now because the
queen is hanging on G4 and again if
Queen captures just rookie the G2 will
be Checkmate so the point is you have to
play something else and there isn't a
move you can play Queen captures and E2
was played uh Rook captures an E2 Knight
captures an E2 and now Queen captures an
H5 so in all the lines that we've seen
the Knight would survive but not in this
one Rook to F2 and now we have Knight
the H4 by proc trying to gain access to
that F3 Square so Rook D to F1 and now
Queen captures an H6 Knight the G3 and
now we have Queen to F6 putting pressure
on D4 pawn bishop to C3 also now that
the bishop is on C3 is basically a pawn
and it no longer serves well as a
Defender to the white king and now Pawn
to G5 just blasting through trying to
open up the G file for the black queen
so Knights the E2 defending on F4 and
now G captures on F4 we have King H1
trying to use the G file for the Rooks
Now Pawn to F3 by proc we have Knight to
G1 Queen to H6 of a threatening some
very nasty discoveries here Bishop to D2
attacks the black queen queen H5 still
threatening nasty discover is now Knight
to H3
and uh you want to play Knight to G2 but
here it would be a mistake because Rook
captures an F3 now defends the Knight so
Prague needs to find a different way
through and he does Bishop to G3
beautifully played attacking The Rook
Now The Rook must move from the f file
and then there is nothing more to be
done or Rook to G1 that was played in
the game this now sort of uh skewers the
bishop the bishop now cannot move but
now Prague finds the elegant Knight to
G2 and he was in this position on move
44 that plan of Anand resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
now everything is being threatened Queen
captures on H3 is a threat there is no
way to defend this the the only way
basically would be to play root captures
on G2 Queen captures and H3 King G1 and
now you give up The Rook captures and
Rook captures but still it's
um uh it's a queen and Bishop versus
rook and Bishop of course completely
unplayable and even okay just King you
move the king you no longer care about
the pin here and that's it uh so yeah
after night the G2 pranavanan resigns
and a brilliant brilliant victory for
pragnananda but as you've seen uh pranav
Anand is truly a master attacker and uh
you know uh he he he said to to
accomplish much he as soon as he became
a grand master he also became the under
16 world champion and uh well uh that
that is spectacular but Prague just
doesn't care he just you know crushes
the world's champion doesn't matter what
or you know if a world champion of this
or that or that Prague will just Crush
you and here yeah he does it again but a
spectacular game and it could have gone
either way uh in this particular game
Prague was the better player uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it big congratulations on this
spectacular feat to both Prague and
India's newest Grandmaster I would like
to thank Jack Obi the con Carlo marovo
marking your paparic sofas versus
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day